the numbers are in from the oscars this
was the lowest rated oscars
ever at not the lowest rated oscars in
the last five or ten years
ever the total viewers dropped
58 year over year
so just from last year but last year was
also a record low
so this is an absolute cratering an
absolute collapse
last year you had 23.6 million people
tuned into the oscars
this year 9.85 million
fewer than 10 million for the first time
ever and in the key demographic 18 to 49
these are the people who are going out
and buying stuff
a decline of 64
15 years ago michael moore got up and
gave a political speech at the oscars
bashing george bush
and he got booed he was actually booed
even by the hollywood liberals
because that sort of thing was frowned
upon the oscars have
had political moments for a long time
but they were few and far between
this really began in the 70s when marlon
brando did not show up to accept his
oscar
and he sent a woman who was part indian
to give us give a speech protesting
the treatment of indians in hollywood
sachin little feather take a listen
my name is sashim littlefeather i'm
apache
and i'm president of the national native
american affirmative image committee
i'm representing marlon brando this
evening and he has asked me to tell you
in a very long speech which i cannot
share with you presently
because of time but i will be glad to
share with the press
afterwards that he very regretfully
cannot accept this very generous
award and the reasons for this being
are the treatment of american indians
today
by the film industry excuse me
and on television in movie reruns
and also with recent happenings at
wounded knee i beg at this time that i
have not intruded
upon this evening and that we will
in the future our hearts and our
understandings
will meet with love and generosity thank
you on behalf of marlon brando
so you can hear in the background when
she goes out and gives the somber speech
about
this relatively minor issue in hollywood
it wasn't even you know
he's not going to take this because he's
protesting the vietnam war or he's not
because he's protesting whatever some
other major
he's protesting the depiction of indians
in hollywood movies in the 70s
what and you hear people bow
and some people applaud and some people
boo and that seems about right
it's gotten so much worse though now
nobody would boo that speech
now you'd have to wow oh wow that was so
beautiful
every speech has to be said sheen little
feather now nobody likes it
the audience is totally going away why
does the left keep this up because they
have the power
we i think like to delude ourselves in
this country and say look
either in the political realm you say
look this is a democracy okay the people
get what they want
democracy is the theory that the common
people know what they want and they
deserve to get it good and hard
as h.l mencken said or this is a
capitalist country okay
the the almighty dollar is what decides
what's going on
if hollywood's pushing a bunch of crazy
propaganda it's because they're going to
make an extra buck out of it
no you get it's both of those are so
reductive
the the political view actually does not
encompass the way that our system of
government works in reality
and the economic view reduces man to a
purely economic
animal which is not what he is that's
not what we are we are much more than
that
what's actually going on here is
something that i document in my book
speechless controlling words controlling
minds available now by the way for
pre-order
what's actually going on is that
radicals who had a v
who have very very unpopular views
were able over decades and decades
to attain positions of power and
influence
throughout the culture in this case
specifically in the entertainment
industry
and they've been able to slowly change
the culture
try to get a hold and create a cultural
hegemony
that the common people are still
resisting they're still tuning this
stuff out
but because they have the positions of
power they're not directly accountable
they're not directly responsible they
are not directly held to consequence
for their craziness eventually
if things train in this direction long
enough and there are no viewers left at
a certain point you think the oscars
are probably going to have to call it
quits but they'll go on for a very long
time this is not a responsive system
right now
this is a minority of radical ideologues
have taken over huge positions of power
everywhere and they're going to keep
pushing their garbage
whether the common people like it or not
they don't like the common people they
think the common people are deplorable
and irredeemable they tell us that to
our face
when they tell you that you should
believe them
hold up do not go anywhere you need to
stay here
not forever just until you smash that
button
and you like and you subscribe and you
make sure that you never miss a video
from us
because youtube some of you messaged me
about this yesterday
there's been some shenanigans with my
show okay and i'm not saying what
just some weird stuff irregularities
make sure that you are getting
notifications every single time
[Music]
you